[Music]
yo out for me check out the hook one
scary fact did you know that was the
first ever hip hop song to top the
Billboard chart that's insane it's crazy
yes Ice Ice Baby will always have a
place in history up or maybe infamy
I'm just saying and now Cameron Mathison
has tosses into that Vanilla Ice ring of
fame was one of those moments where I'm
about to do this like I really went for
this one and I thinking to myself how
did I get myself into this one yes
because all week long we're pushing
Cameron to the limit asking him to do
things that are beyond the reach of mere
mortals tonight's challenge Ken cam
lip-sync battle yeah
backstage at lip-sync battle now that so
much goes into one of these performances
from the props to the wardrobe to the
choreography and I only have 24 hours to
pull it all together and hit that
lip-sync battle stage whoo here we go
let's take it all right I've been
singing this song for years so I think I
got the lyrics down but I need some help
with the dance moves in choreographer
Danielle flaw is the one you're really
good at I don't know you're jumping okay
like I could be like oh my god guys so
there was a blue polo saga did you
stretch yeah all Mart all right just
some stinky now
Waddy is dropping hot with the face kick
did have some pretty fine I wish you all
the success in football
thank you for showing that wall and and
don't show anybody that's okay I think
that went well
alright now that I got some of Vanilla
Ice's moves down sort of let's channel
the overall look and there's nobody
better to help me with that than Jeanne
cheek who is the costume designer here
the head costume designer yes that lip
sync battle
what are we got yeah we have a couple of
different things yes were you I feel
very naked yeah I mean I can feel like
it's like I'm almost wearing enough oh I
get a jacket you do indeed do I need a
shirt Jeanne came up with a lot of great
combos but you'll have to wait for the
final look okay I got about 18 hours
left and I got a rehearse rehearse
rehearse because I can't seem to get the
lyrics down like tight and the dance
dips tight in the same take okay I got
this 18 hours alright here we are the
day of the show I've got an hour and a
half before I gotta go live in from that
audience I hope I have this down the
next time you see me I will be vanilla
ice wish me luck
alright so this guy's the best thing to
come out of Canada this is around a
Drake and tonight he's representing
antechamber tonight as the man who do
anything make some noise the Cameron
mantises king oh my stop collaborate and
listen I sit back my brand new invention
then grabs a hold of me tightly flow
like a Hawking daily and nightly will it
ever stop yo I don't know turn off the
lights and I'm close to the extreme I
Rock a mic like a van do a lot of stage
and watch it chump like a candle if
there was a problem yo I'll solve it
check out the hook while my DJ football
[Music]
like this shake plays on the face like a
ninja I sell it by the gram if there was
a problem yo I'll solve it check out the
hook while DJ revolves it
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
Subban Carrie Mathison
yo you look so much like Vanilla Ice's
then it was over lievable how it's great
Chrissy what did you think I've only
seen you be the utmost professional
interviewer on this entire planet so it
is like that was awesome
it was so fun I can't tell you how much
fun this show is oh my god thank you
thank you yeah you're welcome man Rock
gonna handle questions thanks man give
my man some love give camera some love
Kenny can't can lip-sync well I just did
birds to your mother
well that is right there come on now a
little bit of a shame that that was for
our show and not the real deal right I
could I could have thrown down with LL
for real fantasy you're in fantasy I I
don't know yeah listen lip-sync battle
tomorrow night on Spike check it out
[Music]
you